new research shows that many once
endangered bookstores are booming again
between 2009 and 2015 more than 570
independent bookstores opened in the
u.s. taking the total to more than 2,200
that's about a 35 percent jump after
more than a decade of decline this
surprise recovery may hold lessons for
other small retailers Tony de copal
visited several independent book sellers
where he found the rebound is about more
than just books I am a mom and I
frequently lie to my children on a
Thursday night in the Grange Illinois
I'm also a mom and it's amazing to see a
little version of yourself walking
around in the world it's not so great to
hear a little version of yourself comedy
fans were all but rolling in the aisles
which is good news if you're selling
what's in those aisles that's right this
is a bookstore thanks so much
helped me draw the connection between
books and comedy shows because we host a
lot of different events it's good for
business but it's also good for our
community a lot of times people will say
during my entertainment Becky Anderson
is a co-owner of Anderson books which
began as a pharmacy and has been in her
family for five generations
it's now a small successful chain in the
Chicago area
and it turns out that stores like this
are helping Harvard Business School
professor Ryan Raffaelli
solve an economic mystery ALPHAN say
these are stories of hope he set out to
explain why the number of independent
bookstores has been growing up every
year since 2009 despite cheaper more
convenient ways to buy books online in
national chain stores and with readers
when you get into these things you start
to really go deep like an anthropologist
for you're totally you're like an
anthropologist for technology yeah and
certainly for how markets change and
evolve over time
what raffaeli found is that successful
bookstores yes Mike Anderson's win with
a local appeal a curated selection and
as many as 500 events
a year so buying a book becomes an
active community building as opposed to
just a consumer purchase oh yeah for
sure you talk to people and someone
treats you like a friend and something
they love they're gonna share with you
and you're gonna love it too you can't
get that online quarter-square books in
Cambridge Massachusetts is another
success story says co-owner David
Sandberg he once worked at Google and
bought the store five years ago when I
told my friends at Google I'm leaving
because my wife and I are buying a book
store the universal reaction was that is
so cool is that really a good idea
because there is this narrative of we're
under fire we're getting killed but
that's not the narrative now it helps
that many book stores sell more than
just books well a novelty socks at least
you got one that the title can be shown
on television the cat massager that's
for the life of the mind yeah and then
the dish towel oh the dish towels are
great the margins on socks are better
than the margin the margins are better
on a gift product on toys than they are
on books warm feed supports good writing
but books real physical books are still
the main attraction which is perhaps the
biggest surprise of all you can read on
your phone but we're fine in it so many
people spend so much time on devices
that when it comes to reading for
pleasure they don't want to read it from
a device the best thing about a book is
you can't get email on it yeah you can't
put it up to your ear it's so good the
print books are are really that perfect
thing and by professor Raphael EES
calculations
today's independent bookstores have
evolved to something special through a
kind of natural selection the ones that
have survived
are they the fittest in a Darwinian
sense I think not only are they the
fittest but they've also been sensitive
and had the ability to adapt and
reactivate some of the values that were
there that may have been muted in a race
towards trying to have the cheapest and
largest inventory but do you realize if
what you're saying is true that means we
have the very best bookstores of all
time today I think that's right for CBS
this morning Tony to copal still love
the books
not many of them left anymore but it's
still nice to go in there and I still
like the feel of a book in your hand and
nourishes the soul it really don't know
that books are there having fun
it sounds like they were at a comedy
club in the beginning that story glad
they're doing well buy from your local
bookstore support them and get some
socks too yeah